we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
what is the worst like morning you've
ever had
yesterday like bad occurrences yesterday
what was bad about yesterday what
happened
i think i told you guys but i woke up
pissed
because i wasn't a professional singer
for me i would say 9 11. that's just me
though that's just me personally true
anything
well imagine for a second you live in
new york is this happening to a guy
911 happened in new york oh true no this
is not 911 related this is my it also
happened in washington dc
ah but yeah the pentagon yeah okay they
always sleep on that story
you know man and pennsylvania because
there's no plane there pennsylvania yes
yes that's great yeah pennsylvania being
the last of the three that's right
currencies yes
so imagine you live in new york you're
trying to catch a bus all right
regularly i'm terrible i'm terrible and
then the ground just
gives way underneath you oh [ __ ] sink
into the ground new york underground a
sinkhole 15
20 feet down a sinkhole oh my goodness
bus stop and you're waiting and you just
[ __ ] drop or you walk into the bus
and the whole buses balls
oh those are very different no if the
bus fell i think like
it'll be mainstream news uh it's just a
single car
what the [ __ ] dude did he land in his
destination
he's trying to get
so the florida didn't crumble he just
walked into a hole no there was no hole
before
all right dude sinkholes will [ __ ]
trip you out what the [ __ ]
if you can't comprehend it because i
couldn't really comprehend it until i
saw the video yeah i don't think it
could
be this is what happened all right
shitty person whoa morning after
watch the man in the greens this guy
right here oh no
leonard shoulders
leonard tries to hold on but drops 12 to
15.
it's joe he went straight down and he
was just
falling falling his mom but the debris
was falling and hitting him in the house
i was like
oh man he's gonna pay get paid good
money
yes they were so big and he was scared
to yell out
because he thought that they were gonna
go in his mouth
so yeah once he fell in there uh he was
surrounded by like gigantic new york
city rats
oh my god so his mom was saying he told
him
he told her that he was so afraid to
yell for
help and to communicate back up to the
people that were like hey are you okay
wave or say something if you're okay oh
my god he didn't want to move he didn't
want to say a thing because he was
afraid that they were going to crawl
into his mouth
why would they call it to his mouth if
he said something they would run away
you don't [ __ ]
[Laughter]
though there's like hundreds of rats
there you know remember when i used to
own rats i had rats and they're pretty
nice
no they [ __ ] they from new york
though yeah
different rap new york girls ain't no
joke what brooklyn [ __ ]
they do not get scared no they watch you
walk by
yes the rats are new yorkers too i
didn't know that i was thinking about a
good old l.a rad that's like dude
chill bro chill l.a rat will walk by you
and not even look at you not even wave
any rat would just [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] selfie with you hey look at this
[ __ ] bum
try to [ __ ] post it on tick tock
that's true yeah so then this is uh when
like uh [ __ ] fire department cops
show up
and trying to communicate to him and
they eventually bring in a gigantic
ladder that they
basically like slid down slid down and
he played dead
so the rats just kind of crawled around
him yeah i guess so they don't really go
into detail too much about like
what he was doing down there but he was
down there for 30 minutes
wow in order waiting for people to come
for help and then they're assessing the
situation i'm gonna try to snap my own
neck if i have to [ __ ]
i'm out [ __ ] all that spiders rats no
i want to see what it looks like down
there i don't have a photo of what it
looks like down there but
where's ninja turtles when you need him
exactly i think he had to be a terrible
person
i know he was like you you need to come
to hell now yeah
the chances of that happening i was
thinking it would be better
or funnier if a bird [ __ ] on his head
and that pressure broke the bottom
it was just an extra amount of weight an
eagle [ __ ] dude just uh
yeah so that's the sinkhole so it's like
literally that's a hymn size
yes exactly god was like just you
[ __ ]
like go to him
just you have you ever seen like some
serious
sinkholes where like they take aerial
shots of them and you just look down
into
blackness yeah wow scary as [ __ ] i saw
one in japan like
it was a meme that was going around and
they're like they fixed this
in like uh 24 hours or something but it
was
a whole intersection wow that just saw
and it just [ __ ] went to the ground
and
they have a time lapse of like in 24
hours like a crew came in they just
[ __ ] fixed it dude oh [ __ ] his news
it's taking them like a week to fix this
i mean it's new york dude it's america
like i feel like our major cities are
the most disorganized and [ __ ] up
true yeah also built on like swamp lands
and [ __ ] yeah new york is
i don't know about new york but a lot of
our major cities like like washington dc
is built on a giant swamp oh is it i
didn't know that
but yeah so they've closed down like
three shops in order to fix this tiny
little sinkhole
and uh and i guess they're they're
assessing the fact that maybe there's
more
to the sinkhole like more of it might
give way or whatever scary can you
imagine living your life
not being able to trust the floor
anymore
i thought i could trust you back then
i'ma just test it i walk around stopping
everywhere
it's like it's like walking on thin ice
but it's just concrete
that's scary i would be traumatized [ __ ]
it the next time you like
he had to go he had surgeries and stuff
so like when he fell oh
like he like slid down and like like
part of his arm like
caught onto the concrete and then and he
was literally holes trying to hold
himself up and then he slid all the way
down
and then even then after that his mom
was saying like a debris kept falling on
his head and stuff
so it was it was rough it's funny to
think about it but this guy went through
a [ __ ] ton of crap
did you see people's reactions they
didn't even know what to think
because they had enough time to go oh
[ __ ] and run yeah but people just turned
around and they
watched like i think like was that there
before
what the [ __ ] is that i saw a dude that
looked like he felt
because the way he felt it looked like a
guy that fell butt first in a trash can
with his legs up like he had one leg up
and his arms out right
yeah and it i would have been like what
the [ __ ] i would run the other way
immediately
somebody ran up onto the hole do you see
that yeah yeah i'm gonna show you the
video
just for him you know what's crazy i
would be afraid that the
ground below me is gonna yeah that's why
i would run away because it's like
it's like transformers like dude it's
like an earthquake you know slow motion
playback so he's just walking
and he's just he gives out and then
first impact he tries to good you see
one leg it's his feet yeah his legs are
right there
yeah and people turn around and then
they're like wait wait what
oh it looks like he fell upside down
almost even good reflexes though on his
his back area gave out yeah well he was
too heavy
yeah [ __ ] is nuts is he all [ __ ] up or
what well he survived
he's alive thank god and uh he sustained
a lot of injury scratches and stuff and
the debris falling on his head
um but yeah i think uh the the story now
is at least from coming from his mom
through the interviews i guess this guy
didn't want to be
known as the guy that fell did you do
the interview for me mom
no photo of him no video with him so his
mom did all the talking
we lost all his street cred dude how do
you fight a rat he's going to be rap man
that's his origin story he's redman yeah
but he got big
cigarettes and you don't have matches
yeah that's true because you can't stomp
on a rat they're hard yeah
it's like playing whack-a-mole dude that
would be hard sure i don't know how you
like a little target that's running
around you're like oh
all i know is admitted they crawl up on
you and they [ __ ] bite you and then
you get aids exactly
in movies you get a torch you light the
top of the torso and you're like
yeah yeah indiana jones style yeah
i've never seen a vicious rat they were
always been cute to me true or my i've
seen
mice little ones all right yeah well
they can because like when uh when
uh tiff and i were uh
taking care of pixel gina's uh snake uh
we used to go buy rats to feed feed the
snake
yeah gina made it clear that we're not
supposed to put the live rat
in there so they will fight back they
will fight back they'll scratch the
snake so if the snake is your pet you'll
want your snake to
not get hurt yeah and obviously you know
if you get cut or whatever you can get
you know
connections and stuff from the from the
rats they can scratch the snake's eye
out too sometimes
yeah so rats are pretty feisty if they
if push comes to shove so
yes it only happens like bitch-ass pet
snakes
true they're the domesticated types the
ones i've never really been out and
about so what'd you do
so it's sad and this is the reason why
we shoot basically had to give away
the snake we're like we can't take care
of it for people that own reptiles this
is like
uh normal it's normal yeah so what you
do i have a reptile
the pet store they give you the rat you
buy it it's like two bucks for
a little like feeder rat and then you
take it home
and then and they put it in the bag
right so then you take the bag
and you just hold it over your head and
you smack it into the ground what if you
throw it like this
and it flies out behind you and then
you're like
oh [ __ ] you gotta go catch the rap i've
done an
unsuccessful one this is like the only
one time right so i ever after this
moment i've always done it very clear
like i'm gonna hit it so hard it's gonna
have to die
but i did it one time where i didn't hit
it hard enough and it survived but it
was knocked out
so when i went to like with my tongs to
put it i'm sorry
but i went to get my tongs to pull it
and put it inside the
the cage uh the rat came back and he was
like oh
[ __ ] and i freaked out and i dropped the
entire [ __ ] out of the oh
and everything inside and i was like you
know what i'm not going in there with
the rat in their lives
the snake is out there hunting now they
came out a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the back i'm
not gonna i'm not sticking my hand in
there i just left it alone like that
won't resolve itself
you'll figure it out man up snake oh
[ __ ] it's so scary
what i think the real question is what
he was saying
[Laughter]
i think the real question is how can
snakes survive
without eating any vegetables my mom was
lying to me man that's true you can be a
stone cold killer without vegetables
true very true and then you also you
don't need to really need to chew your
food either because snakes can they just
swallow
yeah there's some snakes that swallow
snakes i wish i never had
mice growing up because that story just
[ __ ] me up dude i'm like oh [ __ ]
monster dude you're a [ __ ] monster
how do you sleep i know
right he's a murderer yeah i had a pet i
wouldn't give you dead right
uh no gina wanted like like like freshly
dead rats because we were like
piggy yeah i heard that they don't eat
them though could you watch
my pet and become a murderer for me they
need to sense the warmth that's because
the reptile like the snakes they have
like actually have bad vision
and then so they need to like
and they they sense the world around
them and they get caught microwave a
dead one
i've seen it done better
i like that get a paper towel
wet it first put it over the dead mice a
little garlic powder
and you're like oh wow we found out the
snakes do not like garlic powder
don't do that
[Music]
you